Bienvenidos en el video pasado Me estaba
quedando algo corta de tiempo pero
alcanzamos a concluir que si yo tengo
una palanca simple como esta y conozco
las distancias desde donde aplico la
fuerza hasta el pivote punto de pollo o
fulcro y conozco la distancia de este
pivote al peso que quiero levantar o en
donde la máquina va a aplicar la fuerza
entonces conozco la relación entre estas
dos fuerzas en el sistema la fuerza de
entrada Aunque Bueno en realidad esto no
deía llamarlo fuerza dos sino fuerza de
entrada o fi o fuerza inicial por la
distancia inicial debe ser igual a la
fuerza de salida Le pongo sub índice o
por la distancia de salida esta sería la
fuerza inicial la distancia inicial o
bueno de
entrada y esta la
distancia de salida y esta la fuerza de
salida hacia
arriba la fuerza de entrada multiplicada
por la distancia del punto donde se
aplica esta fuerza hasta el pivote va a
ser igual a la fuerza de salida por la
distancia del pivote o fulcro hasta
donde se aplica esta fuerza de salida
todo esto lo vimos en el video anterior
que la conservación de la energía y el
trabajo de entrada tiene que ser igual
al trabajo de salida y para qué nos
sirve todo esto vamos a resol varios
problemas con esto digamos que tengo
aquí
una un sistema o una
palanca más o menos
así En
donde aquí tengo mi pivote o mi
fulcro y tengo un peso de este
lado
de 100
newt y aquí
la restricción es que no importa que
pase la fuer la mayor fuerza o el máximo
de fuerza que puedo aplicar aquí son 10
New aquí no conozco Cuál es la distancia
de
aquí acá y tampoco conozco Cuál es esta
distancia Cuál va a ser la distancia
necesaria en este lado para que yo pueda
levantar este peso de 100 N con una
fuerza de 10 New aplicado en este
lado bueno lo que yo quiero es hacer que
la fuerza que entre aquí se multiplique
por 10 para compensar y sea igual a esta
y la pueda levantar entonces tengo
Eh mi fuerza de entrada son 10
New por la distancia inicial o de
entrada que no la conozco y va a ser
igual a la distancia de salida por la
fuerza que quiero levantar que son 10
N Entonces despejo mi
distancia paso este 10 dividiendo y me
queda 10 veces la distancia de salida no
importa qué distancia sea esta tengo que
superarla o multiplicarla por 10 en es
sentido para que yo pueda levantar 10
100 newt con estos 10 New de fuerza
aquí entonces si esta distancia del
fulcro o pivote a este peso es de 5 m
entonces la distancia en donde yo tengo
que aplicar estos 10 New tiene que ser 5
mado por 10 50 New Perdón 50 m en este
lado qué implica Esto bueno puedos
levantar 100 newtons con 10 newt de
fuerza Pero esto implica que voy a tener
que empujar esto hacia abajo 10 veces la
distancia a lo que yo quiero Elevar este
peso entonces la distancia que yo voy a
tener que empujar esta fuerza hacia
abajo va a ser 10 veces mi distancia de
salida que es la distancia a la que yo
voy a querer
levantar este peso o este
objeto esto Qué significa bueno no
existe una máquina que genere trabajo de
la nada o que genere energía de la nada
esto implica que tengo que poner una
energía una fuerza durante cierto cierta
distancia para poder tener un resultado
la energía debe venir de algún lugar y
de hecho la mayoría de las máquinas
pierden energía divido a la fricción u a
otras cosas ahora vamos a resolver otro
problema
vamos a resolver problemas con esta
usando esta misma fórmula y más adelante
usaremos otro o resolveremos otros
problemas sencillos bueno tenemos este
sistema en el que yo tengo esta palanca
tengo mi punto de apoyo o mi fulcro
Aunque Bueno yo no me termino de
acostumbrar a esta palabra mi
pivote aquí tengo un
peso no sé cuál es su su peso o su masa
y tengo que mi distancia de este punto A
dónde se encuentra mi peso es de 5
m y la
distancia de igual de este pivote hacia
donde yo voy a aplicar mi fuerza hacia
abajo es de 35 m y la fuerza que quiero
aplicar en este lado hacia abajo
es de 7
New bueno La pregunta es qué tanto peso
voy a poder levantar de este lado con
este sistema con estas
características bueno tenemos que usar
la misma fórmula pero los momentos y ya
he mencionado Este término antes pero es
posible que ustedes no sepan de qué se
trata los momentos en ambos lados del
pivote tienen que ser iguales o el
momento de entrada tiene que ser el
momento de salid
Entonces qué es el momento es la fuerza
multiplicada por la distancia que es la
distancia de donde aplico la fuerza
hasta el
pivote y desde el pivote hasta donde
está el objeto o donde voy a aplicar la
fuerza de salida Entonces tenemos que la
fuerza de entrada son 7 New por la
distancia son 35 m Aquí tienen que darse
cuenta que el momento no es Trabajo
aunque sea multiplicar alguna distancia
por una fuerza el trabajo sería
multiplicar esta fuerza por la distancia
en donde voy a aplicar esta fuerza hacia
abajo la distancia que yo voy a
recorrer hacia aquí hacia abajo esta
distancia por esta fuerza sería trabajo
sin embargo esta distancia de aquí a acá
va a ser proporcional comparada con la
distancia que tengo de este lado y con
la distancia que yo voy a Elevar este
objeto hacia arriba por eso es que
multiplico por la esta distancia no es
trabajo es
momento bueno Entonces tenemos que eh
Tengo este momento inicial o de entrada
y debe ser igual a los 5 m de esta
salida más
eh la dist la fuerza Perdón multiplicado
por la fuerza que quiero yo Elevar que
es mi fuerza de salida y justamente es
esta fuerza de salida es la que quiero
conocer Entonces está multiplicando
estos 5 m aquí los paso dividiendo y me
va a quedar que mi fuerza de salida va a
ser igual a
es 35 / 5 son 7 entonces me va a quedar
que mi fuerza de salida va a ser igual a
7 * 7 que es igual a 49 New entonces yo
voy a poder levantar mi fuerza o el peso
va a ser igual a 49 n y bueno Esto se
puede ver porque la longitud de este
lado de la palanca es siete veces más
grande que la longitud de este otro lado
Así que cuando se aplica una fuerza de 7
New se multiplica por siete en este otro
lado y por supuesto para poder mover
este bloque digamos que 1 m hacia arriba
voy a tener que empujar esta Fuerza 7 M
hacia abajo y así es como vemos que el
trabajo puesto en este lado va a ser
igual al trabajo que sale en este otro
lado En fin espero no haberlos
confundido Y que ahora tengan una mejor
comprensión sobre cómo funcionan las
palancas en los siguientes videos les
presentaré otras máquinas sencillas como
la cuña Aunque siempre he tenido
problemas refiriéndome a la cuña como
una máquina Aunque lo es y las poleas
nos vemos en el siguiente video